I'm not the supporter of a nation I'm  supporting of a team of football group  11 people were playing soccer  my name is trickeries I'm from Israel  and I came all the way to Paris to cheer  the German national team I'm a big fan  and I hope they'll take the cup when I  was 12 years old  there was the World Cup in 1990 and they  were the best team they won and they got  me fall in love with that the team since  then I'm a big fan and today I'm the  owner of the Facebook page in Israel  that gathers all the German national  team fan you come blame the third  generation of what the grand and grand  grandfather did for Germany do you think  it's okay at the end this is football is  the thing that's supposed to be uniting  people together  doesn't matter which race color gender  nation whatever I didn't see any goals  at the match against Poland I hope  against North Island it will be worthy  of coming here of singles and winning  and going back to Israel very very happy  with a big smile